this video is sponsored by blinkist use
the link in the description and you'll
receive one free week and 25 off an
annual premium membership
considered one of the most consequential
thinkers of the early modern period
Baruch Spinoza proposed new
revolutionary ideas about reason
knowledge free will the nature of God
and Humanity's relationship with
everything
as one of the early pioneers of the
intellectual movements of rationalism
and the enlightenment Spinoza merged in
advanced aspects of philosophy religion
psychology and science seeking new ways
of understanding through reason how one
could live a more joyous and contented
life and greater harmony with the cosmos
foreign
was born in Amsterdam Netherlands in
1632. he was born into a modest Jewish
Family and raised in a
spanish-portuguese Jewish community in
the city he received a traditional
Jewish upbringing in education and is
understood to have been a very
intelligent and scholarly child Espinoza
Grew Older however he also grew
increasingly skeptical of his Jewish
faith and organized religion in general
in his 20s Spinoza would be exposed to
modern philosophy and this would
ultimately lead to the final break that
separated him completely from his
religious upbringing and set him out on
his journey toward new revolutionary
thinking
around the same time when Spinoza was 23
he was banned and shunned by the Jewish
Community including his own family
although the precise reason for his
excommunication is unknown Spinoza's
Masterwork the ethics which would be
published years later in 1677 reveals
aspects of what Spinoza likely asserted
and what likely led to his
excommunication staunch radical
challenges to the fundamental tenets of
religion
throughout his work Spinoza would reject
the validity of things like traditional
concepts of an immortal Soul the
legitimacy of the Bible Divine Law and
the Very nature of God understandably
this did not go over very well for many
at the time Spinoza wrote however I do
not know how to teach philosophy without
becoming a disturber of the Peace
and place of traditional religion
Spinoza wanted to invent new religious
Concepts that moved away from
Superstition Blind Faith and dogma and
instead moved toward objective
understandings of the universe arrived
at through reason
in terms of understanding Spinoza's
attempt to do so it is important to
understand his conception of nature
Spinoza divided the universe or being
into three parts substance attributes
and modes substance here referring to
the material that things are made out of
something in itself that needs nothing
else in order for it to exist or be
conceived attributes being the qualities
that comprise the essence of a thing in
order for it to be conceived and
described and modes being the individual
form a thing takes for Spinoza in order
for things to come into existence and
for anything to exist at all there must
be an underlying substance of nature
that is unaffected by anything else and
does not need anything else in order for
it to exist it must be Universal
infinite and independent a single
underlying infinite substance with
infinite expressions or modes or put
differently one infinite being and
everything that exists is just a
different way of being Spinoza would
refer to this infinite independent
substance as nature or God
whatever is is in God and nothing can be
or be conceived without God Spinoza
wrote
for Spinoza God is not a man a woman or
a human of any sort it does not have any
personal interest special consideration
of humankind or any conscious will at
all any conceptions that liking God to
this for Spinoza are merely an
anthropomorphized projection of the
human imagination
although the term God of course has
religious implications Spinoza's God
arguably requires no religious Faith or
at least very little comparatively
speaking and more importantly one does
not necessarily need to throw out
scientific and rational thinking in
order to discuss agree with or benefit
from the philosophy Spinoza builds from
here Albert Einstein famously said I
believe in Spinoza's God who reveals
himself in the orderly Harmony of what
exists not in a God who concerns himself
with faiths and actions of human beings
this different conception of God is
fundamentally important to the rest of
Spinoza's philosophy because if God is
simply the natural order of the way
things are according to the laws of
nature we can learn what God wants so to
speak and how to live well in the
universe by simply studying and
understanding through reason the nature
of the universe
for Spinoza this is the task of humanity
and the way to a joyous life
specifically this would come from
attempting to understand the causal
relationship amongst things in nature
nature operates through a process of
causality a continuous webbing of cause
and effect everything affected by
something else and everything affecting
something else and since for Spinoza
nothing is outside of Nature and nothing
is separate from nature this process of
causality also includes us including the
human mind and so with this Spinoza
would argue that our sense of Free Will
is an illusion everything we are
everything we do is the product of being
affected by other modes of nature every
feeling emotion thought choice and
action although this might appear
despairing and fatalistic Spinoza would
go on to attempt to argue that through
this knowledge we can obtain a new level
of understanding ourselves and a
different kind of Freedom the highest
activity a human being can attain is
learning for understanding because to
understand is to be free wrote Spinoza
since we are a part of nature bound to
the laws of nature which operate
consistently and verifiably through
causality we can understand and gain
perspective about how things affect us
and we can make better decisions and
evaluations for what we do how we
interact with the world how we respond
and how we treat and perceive things we
can thus become active participants in
the unfolding structure of the universe
in this according to Spinoza we become
free at least in the sense that what we
do and experience will no longer purely
be the result of our external world but
our internal world the intuitions of
nature Guided by our higher faculties of
reason we will thus know when and how to
better moderate relegate silence or
embrace our automatic responses to the
world our emotions and passions and
desires so to best ensure the
preservation and quality of Our Lives
Spinoza wrote human infirmity in
moderating and checking the emotions I
name bondage for when a man is a prey to
his emotions he is not his own Master
but lies at the mercy of Fortune so much
so that he is often compelled while
seeing that which is better for him to
follow that which is worse
[Music]
understanding how things are liberates
one from the chains of how things are a
prisoner is only a prisoner if they are
restricted from where they want to go
and knowing how things inexorably are
and why things are inevitably that way
one becomes wise and content with where
they are mitigating the desire to be
elsewhere the free person is perhaps
merely conscious of the necessity of all
things including their own lack of
freedom
though we are finite and temporal beings
bound to an individual myopic view of
everything the reason and intellect we
can understand things that are bigger
than ourselves we can gain perspective
from things that are bigger than
ourselves we can see existence through
what Spinoza referred to as subspecy
eternitatus under the aspect of Eternity
when we see the whole of nature of which
we are somehow an infinitesimal part
inexorably and forever locked into we
recognize that all things that happen
are inevitable and necessary that what
is good or bad is relative to us but is
an impersonal unfolding of time and
space to everything else that we are no
more but no less important that everyone
and everything is an unchosen part of
the whole a single particle amidst the
Sea of an eternal substance of continual
motion and reconfiguration this
perspective arguably lessens the power
that everything has over Us by realizing
our meagerness and inexorable
interconnectedness with everything
affected by an unending and continuing
line of causality which we did not and
can never really choose we become less
rigidly attached to what has and will
come we become less anxious about doing
exactly the right or wrong things we
become less regretful we become less
scornful we've become more indifferent
to that which we cannot control nor
change we understand the storms the
Lions the snakes the the people we fear
and despise and finally we gain a sense
of poise Liberation and peace
of course Spinoza's ideas are not
without reasonable critiques if
everything is cause and effect including
the mind how can the sort of Freedom
Spinoza defines actually be considered
Freedom if every event is a reaction to
some prior event would not one's own
nature and the ability to reason and
understand also be a product of
causality with not one's own
understanding of causality be a product
of it how can one be free because they
follow a certain intellectual line of
causality but not another though they
never really fundamentally chose or
controlled either moreover can one ever
truly have enough knowledge to have a
sufficient understanding of what is
happening of what is good or best or
true how can one even at the collective
scale of humanity understand enough to
know how everything is working and will
work in the future to properly determine
what is truly and enduringly optimal
though many questions like these are
still left open in Spinoza's work his
ability to amalgamate the various
methods of human thinking break free
from from indoctrination and Antiquated
conceptions of being and innovatively
Advance the possibility and methods of
human understanding he opened the doors
for new ways of considering questions
like these and ultimately changed the
course of everything
forever
[Music]
this video was sponsored by blinkist one
of the most difficult parts of actively
learning throughout life is simply
maintaining the time and focus though no
one would disagree with the obvious
value of regularly learning and reading
sifting through tons of complete books
can often be cumbersome and difficult
and many of us neglect The Habit
blankest is a unique app that helps
solve this problem by facilitating
assisting and supplementing easy
efficient and strong reading Habits by
condensing over 5 500 of the best
non-fiction books and podcasts across 27
different categories blinkis allows you
to read or listen to 15-minute book
explainers covering a huge range of
information and authors allowing you to
easily discover new books derive new
understandings and refresh yourself on
important ideas and lessons whenever and
wherever you are if you're interested in
further exploring rationalism and
Western philosophy in general blinkist
has plenty of fantastic titles the
provide insights into Major Works like
meditations on first Philosophy by Renee
Descartes critique of pure Reason by
Emmanuel Kant and Beyond Good and Evil
by Friedrich Nietzsche which blinkis
provides thoughtfully organized
breakdowns of allowing you to easily
Traverse through the seminal works of
philosophy and uncover groundbreaking
ideas that changed history and will
perhaps change you through blinkist's
feature blinkist connect premium users
can also share their account with
another person for the same price
essentially providing two memberships
for the price of one click the link in
the description or scan the QR code to
start your seven day free trial and get
25 off an annual premium membership the
free seven-day trial can be canceled at
any time within the trial period
and of course thank you so much for
watching in general and see you next
video
[Music]
[Music]